schönes bild hast du hier am start die
kamera so ja und jetzt jetzt habe ich es
nochmal jetzt wieder nur das video lässt
das laufen machen dass ich laufen so wie
der ganze laufen die tiere so wieder
aber so gering
[Musik]
die junge leute herzlich willkommen zu
diesem video heute geht es um mein
equipment und das equipment das baby und
ich benutze nur um regens videos zu
erstellen natürlich auf meine videos
einiger video und schnitt begeisterte
freunde von mir und ich haben uns
überlegt ein video über unsere kunden zu
mensch und jeder mache ich war so kurz
und diese der in das video der anderen
kommt das tut sie gar so jetzt geht es
erstmal zu den equipment dass ich für
mein image des videos benutzer hier
direkt optimistisch habe ich das mal so
ausgebeutet oder fangen wir an mit der
kamera die kamera ist leider nicht
repräsentiert ein spiel wie in afrika
dabei dann gehen wir mal zu paul eine
baugleiche kehren also thomas hallo also
wo ist die sms sagt mir besseren es
müsste also wenn du jetzt nicht hier ist
die kunst aber kann ich also habe ich
die klasse wirklich halten es steht und
die ist super gut für fotografie und
es ist sogar gefüllt video natürlich als
team spielt und 26 euro und eine sms zu
herzen wir uns nicht gereicht auf jeden
fall diese kamera benutzt mit derselben
es tue davon gibt es auch über coole
szene zu sehen wie dieses video
benötigte k4 und das ist meine eigene
kamera auch für das video benutze ich
dieses rudel ihr mikrofon auf jeden fall
benutze ich dieses mikrofon erst seit
kurzem ich glaube das ist sogar das
erste video welches ich damit drehe das
habe ich mir unter anderem die kauffeld
natürlich politik machen beides von
einem anstieg von weil der ruf ist auch
der imam ihr gehalt und andererseits
weil ich auch das für pc benutzer weil
man mal mit single disc mit anderen
leuten quartal wir fangen wir an mit den
kunden haben und zwar ist das hier der
simon crane
das ist ein so genanntes kimmel und ein
gimbel stabilisiert quasi die kamera auf
drei achsen als ich das ding zum ersten
mal bei leon und anders gesehen hat ich
war richtig raus ich komme ich bin gar
nicht mehr weggekommen
dieses teil funktioniert das ist einfach
immer noch so ein stück magie und ich
benutze immer noch gerne erstmal super
gerade ergebnissen ablesen und zweitens
weil es einfach pure energie ist ebenso
hier der dame bleibt für diese simple
der ist dazu da dass man hier auch mit
zwei hunden raten kann was für ein
bisschen mehr stabilität sorgt und was
natürlich auch der besorgt dass man zu
einer klemme hier noch mikrofon an
diesem griff presse bekannt und zwar
auch mit zu einem kabel denn diese
mikrofonkabel sie ja wir unschwer
erkennen könnt immer sehr sehr kurz ich
muss ich doch dazu sagen dass ich das
geben wir meistens ohne diesen damit
benutzer einfach nur weiß weniger platz
wegnimmt und stade ausbauen kann und
etwa gerade ob ich rede die ganze zeit
schon wieder richtig richtig schnell
gemerkt ich versuche es zu unterbinden
als nächstes haben wir diese stativ hier
und ich habe lange zeit über stative 14
und 20 30 euro
weil ich dachte das ist eigentlich die
girls und das ist statt einfach nur
gerade stehen muss aber seitdem in
dieser stadt bin ich anfang so zufrieden
mit diesem kauf ich habe erstens eine
gute stadt gekauft welche ist eben
stabil ist und welche man sogar ein bein
als monat abschrauben kann das heißt man
kann die kamera auf einen sohn bein
stellen und dann kann man das zum
beispiel der menschenmenge ganz ganz
verhalten und colleges damit machten
zusätzlich zu diesem stativ gibt es hier
auch noch einen fluid kopf von jura
der ist dafür zuständig dass die kamera
bewegungen die man mit diesen
initiativen machen kann sehr sehr weich
sind
dann haben wir die großen sachen
eigentlich schon durch hier haben wir
nochmal meine kopfhörer die ich benutze
große qualcomm 25 sind das die
amerikaner funktion und zwar noise
cancelling wenn man diesen schalter
umschaltet körpern außengeräusche viel
viel schlechter weil felix ich habe ein
blendender aufnahmen liegt nicht
ausschließlich an berater für toiletten
gesagt beim auf einer million abonnenten
körper als das programm hat es keine
das habe nicht an wenn es nicht läuft
weiß sonja haben wir bei medien wollte
aus der mikro hallo also heute ja
eigentlich der piloten masse weil das
wirklich aber machen nicht aber genau
ein beliebiges bildschirmaufnahme
programm adobe erst war auch unter
programme us open source ist fragt ihn
freilich anders denn das super geile
sache art bietet eine fehlermeldung ein
wenn man kein speicherplatz hat anstatt
durchzulaufen zu sagen ja 70 minuten 18
90 alles verdeckt dann in einem stopp
auch keine fehlermeldung erst irgendwann
wird sich jetzt ein paar beachten fürs
kilowattstunden produktiv investiert wie
youtube ist dann weiß sie müssen nur
aufnehmen und wir kriegen nicht mal hin
zu versiegen speichert was ich bin auch
nicht der typ dafür wie man kameras hält
ja ja ich nehme
mobilität und da hat ja mal zur seite
oder es geht ja warum nicht
das wird ein schönes bild hast du hier
am start muss auch immer noch wie ich
weiß nicht warum ich bin da wirklich
wirklich schön hier richtig geil dass es
tatsächlich auch wirklich einfach
behalten hat also nicht was der kamera
über die kamera so ja und jetzt jetzt
hat es nochmals reduziert wieder nur das
video games laufen machen dass ich
laufen sowie der kann zu laufen mit
ihren sowie da aber sowieso schon oma
danke herr produktive hilfe hier ich war
bei diesen kopf hinhalten sieht geil aus
noise cancelling haben man hört
natürlich trotzdem noch außengeräusche
aber das stimmt sie aus dem geräusch auf
jeden fall sehr sehr krass ab das ist
natürlich ziemlich praktisch wenn man
hier bearbeitet und wenn man natürlich
mit baby in einem büro arbeitet man kann
sich einfach deutlich besser auf seine
arbeit konzentrieren während ried und
das ist glaube ich auch die antwort
darauf wie kann ich arbeiten mit
rebellion büro während er die ganze zeit
auf jeden fall gehe ich dann hier noch
mal gerne kurz auf dieses gerät ein das
ist im prinzip ladegerät für batterien
da steckt auch schon eine batterie drin
und zwar eine neue strategie und ich
habe gerade gelobt es ist kein ladegerät
batterien sondern ein ladegerät für
akkus und der ist 9 volt akku und damit
habe man diese mikrofon hier betreiben
die wir immer benutzen um aufzunehmen
das ist das video mal übrigens des
weiteren kann man diese kein dreifach
akkus damit auf laden täglich in der
benutze um eine busen oscar sico
aufzuladen die übrigens leon auch als
die habe ich auch von leon genauso wie
das gimbel habe ich im nachgekauft
credits anleger auf jeden fall mal halt
dann wollte ich euch noch mal einen raus
zeigen diesem aus einem 12 freiwillig
betasten und oben nochmal zwei tasten
mit denen man zwischen verschiedenen
tasten profilen greifen kann man kann
also theoretisch so viele
tastenbelegungen auf diese maus
klatschen wie man eigentlich möchte und
das ist vor allem für schnitzler sehr
geil es für schneller dann wird alles
wenn man nicht immer irgendwelche
komischen tastenkürzel benutzen
wenn man nicht immer erst einstellungen
effekt bleibe aber gehen muss sondern
wenn man einmal diese taste direkt
infekte man will zusätzlich was für ein
schnelles ja sehr wichtiges benutze ich
diese festplatten gehen das ist die
samsung t5 ist eine externe ssd die
ermöglicht es mir quasi das ich schon
immer und überall streiten kann und hier
immer meine firma dabei habe ich nämlich
immer auf diese festplatte die sind
nicht so schnell dass ich direkt das
filmmaterial von ist als platte
informiere einziehen kann
das folgenden vorteilen und zwar wenn
ich gerade im büro bin und sage ich
würde gern zu hause war gar nicht
einfach diese festplatte aus stück sind
diese festplatte bei meinem pc oder bei
meinem laptop zu hause anstecken und ich
dann direkt weiter schneiden ohne dass
ich irgendwie nach noch warten auf
meinem pc ziehen muss und deswegen habe
ich mir davon zwei klassen jeweils 500
gigabyte super investition wenn ihr
irgendwas von miami kommt man auch haben
wollten gut meinen beschreibungen da
hatte ich solche links vor allem diese
festplatten kann ich nur sehr sehr
empfehlen und jetzt die die
versprochenen ausschnitte der videos die
ich vorhin erwähnt habe das sind alles
auch nicht über die coole videos machen
checkt auf jeden fall mal den kanal ab
das sind ohne der video beschreibung
verlinkt und jetzt zieht der kurze
ausschnitte von den kunden weiter zu
verwenden junge leute also was denn hier
ich lade jede woche zwei videos zu den
themen video kaffee und fotografie auf
meinen kanal hoch und das hier ist mein
equipment
[Musik]
nein
die funkantenne films und das hier ist
mein equipment ich großes hauptkamera
die comics gh 42 walimex pro sim
objektiven einmal das 16 meter zählt 22
und einmal das 35 meter at 15 sei die
kann man auch die objektive keinen
bestand haben bin ich dazu verpflichtet
sie auf einen rektor zielen der fall
habe ich einen von der firma film city
mit einem produkt von der firma better
off micro für birol schoss und um
wirklich sein benutze ich die sony alpha
support 100 und um die schärfe gut
erkennen zu können ein monitor von input
diesen finden und jannik von karat filme
around auf dem wir über liegen comedy
und unterhaltungs videos machen geht
zeigen wir euch einen kurzen einblick in
unser equipment
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
ich hoffe konnte das mitleben machen
wenn ihr bock drauf hat mich weiter zu
begleiten ob sie sagen weise die ich
gerade hierdurch leben darf dann
abonniert doch gerne und las auch gerne
die videos am boden da wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder macht's gut zu
schaffen
[Musik]